so much bad news these days we're back
with some good news and it's a fox news
alert two big jobs reports
just released moments ago let's see nine
minutes ago
4.8 million jobs were added in june
economists had predicted maybe around
three million as you can see
that is a gigantic blowout number
ainsley
that's right the national unemployment
rate dropping from
13.3 in may to 11.1
brian yup the weekly jobless claims
report also out just over 1.4 million
americans filing for unemployment last
week
that's a little higher than what some
economists predicted more than 48
million americans have filed for
unemployment since the start of the
pandemic
let's bring in senator from south
carolina lindsey graham senator
first off your take on this and what it
means for another rescue package just on
on first take well it means we need a
rescue package that would hit the gas to
make the economy grow faster
this is really good news it means
america is coming back economically
people are going back to work there's
confidence that you can
actually open up the country so the
president is proposing a payroll tax cut
that would put money in the pocket of
consumers and businesses
that would stimulate the economy an
infrastructure bill to give america a
facelift with our road bridges and ports
that would set in motion future job
creation
we need to make sure you don't pay
people more in unemployment benefits
than they get to work
that will help get people back to work
i'm even willing to
do a minimum wage increase there are so
many things liability reform so you
can open up without being sued congress
needs to act in july
to continue this trend if we had the
right kind of stimulus package
we would be going through the roof by
october in terms of economic growth okay
i know y'all are taking a two-week break
when are y'all back and when do you
think this next relief package will be
released
uh just as soon as we get back we need
to get off our ass and get this done
bottom line here is the bottom line here
is we got an
opening take it it may not last now the
coronavirus
can be a wet blanket in all this
reopening if we don't control it
so president trump needs to get on the
phone and call all the governors
what can i do to help you what do you
need that you don't have
let's really double down on testing
because that gives us insight
how to control the virus and a vaccine
and
therapies are on the way i'm i'm
increasingly optimistic that we're going
to
control the virus and reopen the economy
smartly and
and that's really the key because even
though the numbers are going up
you know we're approaching 50 000 new
cases yesterday
uh we're figuring out how to manage it
and you know with
social distancing and mass and
pharmaceuticals and things like that
so when you look at that and you think
you know we shut down the whole world
for the most part
for about 100 days did we overdo it
on that or was that just part of the
learning curve because in the beginning
we didn't know where that was going and
i hear a lot of chatter on
on cable tv i need to probably watch
less of it
you're one of the chatters sir yeah
except for your show
uh here's the deal president trump was
told if you do nothing and let the herd
immunity mentality take over you're
going to lose 2 million americans
we're going to probably have 180 000
dead after having shut the whole world
down
so i think president trump's decision to
shut down the economy and focus on
protective equipment coming back to
america vaccines and therapies and
testing
save probably a couple million people's
lives if you don't think this is deadly
by now
what would it take to convince you this
virus is deadly
right let's switch to russia beth sanner
is the president's briefer and beth
center did not
verbally beat the president on the
threat of the russians if the the fact
is proven correct
the russians giving the taliban money to
kill
americans now seth moulton says from
what he knows
the president committed treason where's
lindsey graham stand
well i don't know if congressman moulton
has been briefed
but i would say i'm a fairly hawkish guy
would you agree with that
absolutely russia has been up to no good
in a lot of different places and i
have a whole lot of affection for
putin's russia
but i do understand the military i think
the system got it right
you had contradictory intelligence we
increased force protection
just to be cautious but i can't imagine
briefing the president united states
about this allegation given the nature
of the intelligence
now where were all these democrats when
benghazi was on fire
when they were calling for help from the
consulate the president united states
obama was brief and went to bed and
never called anybody for a day and a
half
while our people were being slaughtered
in benghazi where's the outrage then
the intelligence here in my view does
not justify
a nation-state conflict with russia
yeah well you were brief though right
and what it is i was briefed and i asked
a lot of hard questions
and you know you don't tell the
president of the united states
everything you would tell a second
lieutenant
right exactly senator um you know given
what we now know
you know about the briefer and all that
other stuff as well
um it shouldn't surprise anybody that
it's a big story in the new york times i
mean that's what they do
they come up with these big stories to
make donald trump look bad
and it's all bs it's not he wasn't
briefed
and there there was no consensus as a
matter of fact the most reliable form of
intelligence
gathered around this episode uh was
against russia giving money to the
taliban the iranians are giving money to
the taliban russia has been given
weapons to the taliban
the point is that this president and i
disagree with him sometimes
about military footprints over there to
protect us here
but when it comes to american personnel
on the ground in harm's way
this president has an unwavering desire
and commitment to protect our troops on
the ground if you don't believe me
ask the 400 russian mercenaries that
were killed in syria when they
threatened our troops yeah they were
wiped out
um yeah you can't ask them because
they're dead real quick call
rover an editorial today in the wall
street journal saying the president's
got to reset
in the next few months or he's going to
lose do you believe the president has to
reset his
re-election uh yeah i think he's got to
go on the offense i don't know if he's
going to lose or not but he's got a hell
of a story to tell he should start
telling it
you want to bring back protective
equipment in this country from china i
got a bill that would give a tax credit
to make ppe
here and put it under the berry
amendment treating it like military
uniforms a national security asset
china lied and america's americans died
let american citizens who sue the
chinese communist party
do an infrastructure bill you go on
offense mr president
in your second term what do you want to
do finish the job of your first term
keep building the wall fix a broken
immigration system
more judges make sure ron never gets a
nuclear weapon
i think the president's right on all of
these issues
he's for law and order and joe biden is
being controlled by the most radical
people in this country
this election is still donald trump's to
lose but prosecute the case mr president
hey uh senator graham before you go i
saw you played
golf with the president over the weekend
who won
he i've never seen him play this well i
mean he's got more on his shoulders i'm
hoping okay you know he's a little
distracted
he beat me like a drum i mean it was
amazing
shot 74. always lose to the boss
i'm not joking i mean if i could beat
him i would
senator south carolina's in our thoughts
and prayers uh dealing with kova down
there and we lost that pilot at shaw air
force base so sure
thanks so much for what you do for that
great state thank you thanks for joining
us